محاور الشمال والجنوب اذا تشهد مواجهات
ضاريه مصدر قيادي في كتائب القسام يعلن
تنفيذ كمين محكم شرق حي التفاح امس الجمعه
ادى الى تدمير ناقل الجند وقتل عشره جنود
اسرائيليين من نقطه صفر القسام اكدت ايضا
بالصوت والصوره خوضه اشتباكات حاميه
الوطيس شرق مدينه غزه وخصوصا في الشعف
وجبل الريس وحي التفاح ومنطقه الدرج كمائن
وعبوات قذائف ترادف اوقعت وفق القسام
الجنود الاسرائيليين بين قتيل وجريح
بالاضافه الى تدمير الدبابات تحت وابل من
القذائف على جباليا وبيت لاهيه هذا وقد
كثفت المقاتلات الاسرائيليه وسلاح
المدفعيه القصف على المنطقه الوسطى خصوصا
مخيمات البريج والنصيرات والمغازي حيث
الكثافه الانسانيه العاليه من اللاجئين
والنازحين من اهل القطاع ومع ايلاء قوات
الاحتلال اهميه للمعارك في خان يونس تعل
عن بدء هجوم في منطقه خزاعه والمحاور
الجنوبيه هذه تشهد مواجهات ضاريه وقصف
متواصلا لتجمعات الجنود في عبسان
ورفح